spoke to a guy before this and he said
America First you weren't happy with
that Li Israel would not exist without
America so no America First for you no
are you an American yes and you don't
want to put America First no the idea
that Israel would not exist without
America is also not true when the
British Empire ended in 1948 they left
the British left and then there was just
land there the Arabs will get some there
was a the 1947 un partition plan you
Arabs will get some you Jews will get
some Israel would have been much smaller
than it is today but the Jews said okay
we'll we'll take it we'll take it it
would be nice you know we just got
Holocaust it would be pretty nice to
have a little something that we could
call ours and not be hunted and hounded
down as we have throughout our history
but the point is they didn't get the
state because of America America did
recognize the state shortly after Harry
Truman did recognize the state I think
about a day after they got a state by
living on the land and create taking a
desert and turning it into a paradise
that is that is now unfortunately not
much of a paradise